Here, the solution was negative infinite to negative 3 or 1 half to positive
infinity. Nice algebra skills if you got these two integrals. To begin to solve
this quadratic inequality, we want to subtract 3 from both sides. So we have 0
on the left and the quadratic expression on the right. We can flip the entire
inequality around, so we'll have 2y squared plus 5y minus 3 is greater than 0.
These two statements here are exactly the same. They're just written in the
reverse order. Once we have this inequality, we want to find the 0s. If we find
the 0s, we can set up our number line with three intervals. So we'll factor the
left-hand side of the equation to get 2y minus 1 times y plus 3. We set each
factor equal to 0 and we solve for the values of y over here. In this case, y
could equal 1 half, and in this case, y could equal negative 3. We use positive
1 half and negative 3 to create the intervals on our number line. For interval
I, we'll try the number y equals negative 5. When we substitute negative 5 in
for y, we'll get the statement 22 is greater than 0. We know this is true, so
this is included for our solution set. For interval II, we'll try the number y
equals 0. When we plug in 0 for y, we'll be left with negative 3 greater than
0. We know this is not true, so any of these numbers within this region are not
part of our solution. And finally, for the third interval, we can try the
number y equals 1. When we plug in 1 for y, we'll get 4 greater than 0. This is
a true statement, so we can include these values as part of our solution set.
We use parentheses at negative 3 and positive 1 half, since we need to be
greater than 0, we can't be equal to it. So our final solution is negative
infinity to negative 3 or 1 half to positive infinity.